when i see you becoming it's it's
star six to unmute yourself when you are
forced to speak but you will be able to
hear everything
if you could just mute your laptop
right
are we okay to go on
yes ready to go right
good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinets
uh looking at the agenda apologies for
absence do we have any apologies for
absence and
neither we've got apologies from
councillor pemberton and councillor
parker will be joining us um
hopefully very soon do you want me to do
a raw call through everybody else
i think that may well be appropriate
okay so we start with yourself if you
can perhaps just let me know if you can
see and hear everything as you go
through so counselor jefferson
councillor jefferson i can see it and
hear everything
thank you councillor cargill council car
girl i can see in here everything
okay councillor harvey council harvey
can hear and see thank you
thank you councillor jennings councillor
turning second here and see all
proceedings
thank you councillor parry good
afternoon everybody yes i can see
and hear everything and i have read all
the reports for the meeting today
thank you thank you councillor shenton
what do you mean you're still muted
i just haven't mastered the unmuting by
the looks of it
i can hear and see all proceedings
thank you and counselor wally hoggins
how's the willie huggins i can see and
hear everything thank you i'm just
popping off thank you we we also have
with us council
junaid dixon and o'donnell
and i can see and hear everything that's
counselor
i can see and hear everything it's
counts for donald
right in that case we shall begin
disclos
disclosures of interest anyone
yes mr chairman councillor harvey
uh item 11 uh i don't know whether this
is necessary but i declare an interest
as a dog owner
thank you councillor harvey
um in which case then uh leader
chair uh i also declare councillor
shenton declare
an interest as i am a dog owner
thank you councillors harvey and shenton
minutes turning to the minutes of the
previous meeting
are we happy with the minutes or are
there any issues on the minutes
please agree
with the counselors could make a note in
the chat if there's anything
um that they are uh that they wish to
raise otherwise we could particularly
read i would take it as read thank you
anne
so we take the minutes as read so moving
on to the next item on the agenda
which is the site allocations plan
and in the absence of councillor
pemberton it falls to me
to lead on this item um
first to make very clear the site
allocations plan
is for public consultation
and i think in this site allocations
plan there are some
important points starting with two very
general ones
if one actually reads the site
allocations plan
i think one gets a very clear
understanding of the complexity of the
planning landscape
i think the second thing to really note
is
the constraints under which we as a
district council
operate we have to work within the
planning law
and we have to work within laid down
rules
would now like to draw cabinet's
attention to some specific
paragraphs paragraph 112
the context for the site allocations
plan is set by the course strategy
and the site allocations plan is
subservient to the core strategy
that's probably got some significance
for
uh 713 in the
site allocation strategy
if we actually then look at paragraph
116
uh following the consultation assuming
we agree to consultation
the comments will be analyzed to prepare
a proposed submission version of the
site allocations plan
for further consultation
if we look at uh 0.119
uh officers are already embarking
on a course strategy review and the
following paper will cover that
the core strategy review that's been
tackled now
could take up to 2024
there are also two papers out for
consultation on planning
but the advice from both those papers is
not the poor
core strategy so there's
merit in pursuit progressing with the
site allocations plan
that will provide clarity and certainty
to both communities
and the development industry in the
intervening period
as i mentioned there are two government
consultations out at the moment
changes to the existing planning system
and the planning white paper
i would say we have made very robust
responses to the consultation
we prepared and sent out a briefing note
to our mps
if we turn to point
one two one
uh just on the
we're not going to rehearse the
justification through reserve housing
sites
but they're there to meet four purposes
maintain the five-year housing land
supply which is absolutely vital
meet additional housing needs from
expansion of jlr
gate and light on heath meet additional
housing needs from coventry and
warwickshire housing market area
and need additional housing needs from
outside coventry in warwickshire
and if one looks at 0.125
the reserve sites are in addition
to the minimum requirement of 14 600
contained in the cost strategy
just in terms of the
five-year housing land supply paragraph
1
2 13 it's proposed that a trigger of 5.5
is applied that's because we cannot wait
until supply falls below
five years before taking action because
the way the nppf is written
as soon as supply falls below five years
relevant policies relating to the supply
of housing
cease to be applicable in other words as
far as our district
is concerned if we have less than a
five-year housing land supply
basically it's a free-for-all
so we want to buffer of a half
years worth of supply i should say that
at the moment
uh i believe that our five our
housing land supply is in the order of
six and a half years but the final
figure needs
confirmation if i move to point
one to 21
there's a specific point there about
meeting
needs of the greater birmingham area and
those have been taken into account
in the site allocations plan
not only that 0.12 21
does outline why the duty to cooperate
plays such an important part in
both the course strategy and the site
allocations plan
uh i'm going to ask mr carefort in a
moment
to consider some of the issues around
136 and 137
and the revised uh section 713
uh that's been proposed to put into the
site allocations plan final point i want
to make
is that endpoint 2 2
material changes to the site allocations
plan
would delay consultation with a knock on
effect of delaying submission to the end
of 2021
i'm aware that the uh published
document says 2020 in fact it should be
2021
so mr carefort can you just take us
through
please if you would uh
the underlying rationale between
uh underpinning the
revised section 713
that's substituted with the update sheet
and could you please in particular
outline the significance of the core
strategy
in this mr carefort please
certainly do leader thank you um
just to advise that members you have
an update sheet uh in front of you
that's got a revised
uh section uh some team uh
set out with some track changes
uh shown um that is in last
[Music]
uh their recommendations uh included
within that
um really um questioning
the rationale for including
uh this particular site at meonvale
within the site allocation span as a
standalone
uh proposal it was previously a reserve
site it's
been proposed now as a standalone
specific proposal um it is
an area of woodland but neon vale or
long martin depot
itself is a large rural brownfield site
uh as set out in the strategy itself
so what that policy does is it does
establish
the principle of development from wider
lma
that's right um depot uh neonvale site
um and that's why it's not appropriate
uh as a reserve
site and what we're trying to do here is
provide
certainty um and to be proactive
and manage change in immune veil
and that's why we think it's appropriate
to include it
within the the consultation document so
just to retreat it is a consultation
document this is a draft
not um asking members to agree
the final version but what i think is
right to do
is by being uh proactive we put
ourselves in a stronger position to work
with the landowner
and get the best outcome uh for this
site
the the longer history of the site um
part of the
the land in question uh there is a
consent
or there was a consent for holiday uh
lodges i think it is
uh on part of the land so the council
has accepted in the past
some development on the island parcel
given that context
given the uh the inclusion within the
core strategy
we do think it's appropriate that we
consult
on its inclusion such allocation span at
the current time
um that's the background leader
what members have is the revised section
713
including the recommendations from osc
some further tweaks
to the explanatory text just to elude
and set out some of the
uh explanation i've alluded to
um and the last thing leader if i may
just want
i'm on it were the recommendations
revised set of recommendations so
recommendation
for is to take account of
that new section and then there's just a
tweak to recommendation two
there's a typo
so you should say the um adoptions
version
decide that allocations plan is the one
we are agreeing
for consultation here today thank you
leader
thank you uh and i've just realized that
we had two public speakers
and i should have called those first
should i not
now that's perfectly fine we've set the
scene and we also have two councillors
that would like to speak
and then we also have some of the
committees that want to speak as well so
and if
do you want to go to the public speakers
now and then we can all the
public speakers then the councillors who
wish to speak
then the people who are in the cabinet
lovely
thank you
okay can we call our first public
speaker please i believe that you are in
the meeting and you're muted
rosemary
you need to press star six to unmute
yourselves
hi it's alicia here i'm not sure where
rosemary is
okay you were splitting the time between
you so um
do you want to start you have five
minutes between you as we advise so do
you want to start alicia and then
rosemary
is that okay yes it is yeah go ahead
all right good afternoon everyone
firstly on behalf of the friends of me
unveil woodland walk
which already has over 500 facebook
members
thank you for the opportunity to present
our concerns today
i'm rosemary kidd and i'm supported this
afternoon by fellow resident emil vale
alicia johnson to provide absolute
clarity from the start
the friends of neonvale woodland walk
are totally opposed to any built
development
within the myanvale woodland area we're
calling for proposal rural four
to be deleted from the site allocations
plan
and for the whole of the woodland to be
designated and safeguarded
as a local green space alongside this we
are seeking a policy in the site
allocations plan
to safeguard the trees the biodiversity
and accessibility of the woods
our appeal is founded on three
fundamental issues
firstly the proposed allocation is
contrary to national
and core strategy planning policies
secondly the importance of the woodland
in the current climate emergency that
threatens us all
and thirdly the significant negative
impact that this proposal
would have upon the health and
well-being of the local community
the council has adopted a very clear
stance on the woodland at moonvale in
core strategy policy as11i
this clearly states that sort of
development proposals on the site
must take into account the need to
retain and enhance
extensive open landscape areas and
woodland plantations
the council clearly acknowledges the
importance of the woodland in battling
against the current climate emergency
by including it as a case study in its
sbd on climate change
which was approved earlier this year
national planning policy in the npps
makes it clear that when selecting sites
for housing development
they should not have any adverse impacts
upon important environmental assets
the proposal for 300 houses would result
in a loss of hundreds of trees
from an important environmental stepping
stone on the greenway
wildlife corridor this is contrary to
mppf paragraph 174
we also refer to the revised wording of
the specific requirements of rural floor
in the updated cabinet
we are very concerned that this would
not safeguard the woods and its
biodiversity
it could result in a loss of all of the
landscape screening belt
described as landscape as plantation
woodland
which covers a significant area of the
woods
the destruction of any part of the
woodland will impact on the delicate
balance of wildlife and biodiversity
and not just the woods but the adjacent
streams and ponds
where there are protected species it is
not clear
how the developer can propose a net gain
in biodiversity on the site
and so much will be destroyed even in
the best case scenario it will take
decades to deliver
the need for accessible green
infrastructure for our growing community
of over 2 000 people
must be recognized to promote our health
and well-being
i'll hand over to alicia johnson
thanks me the charity mind
states that bringing nature into your
everyday life
can benefit both your mental and
physical well-being
these mature woodlands with their two
miles of walks and picnic areas areas
have become a real lifeline to residents
of the unveil
and the surrounding areas especially
during the current pandemic
during a time in which mental well-being
has become such a prominent issue
this easily accessible and beautiful
outdoor space
has provided an oasis within an
otherwise increasingly developed
area with direct access from the
greenway
the woods are in constant use providing
a relaxing escape
a stimulating space to exercise and an
opportunity
for our inquisitive children and young
children to get away from their screens
and connect with nature with this in
mind
we would stress to you the intangible
value of this brilliant green space
to local residents in the same breath
we would also condemn the description of
the woodlands as nothing more than a
vacant lanfield site as grossly
inaccurate and misleading
whilst we fully appreciate the
complexity of the decision-making
process
for our local representatives we will
conclude
by asking you to consider your own
legacy as councillors
we urge you to reject this proposal and
seize an opportunity
to make a genuine long-lasting and
beneficial
impact upon our local community as well
as our environment
thank you thank you
uh councillor pertegallo do you wish to
speak now
if council portuguese have an um issue
speaking perhaps see
if councillor hensha siroffen is
available to speak first and we can give
councillor peter geller a call
councillor hensha seraphine hello
good afternoon all uh i have uh very
grave concerns of
um putting allocated sites where there
is woodland
um we are in a climate emergency
and the benefici of trees are immense
and this site in mapabura green
have had many um oh
what would i say um reports
on it over the years and all the reports
that i've read
say that this area should be kept as a
space
green space between the settlement of
redditch
and mapabura green
as these woods are mature now there is
lots of wildlife in there including
quite a few deer
but this is to keep the boundary between
reddish
from uh merging with mapabura green
uh this to me is one of the most
important things
otherwise mapleboro will lose its
identity
as a village so i just want to make it
clear
that it this may need to be looked at
again
it's over the years that has been um
looked at many times on the
adr inquiry and it's
always come up with as you should be
left
as an open space between the two
settlements
okay plain and simple
thank you councillor henshaw seraphine
uh
councillor potter gala
yes sorry amir um thank you very much
um can you hear me yes perfect
so i see that some changes have been
made to 713
but these changes were short of
protecting the woodland i'm referring
again at the meonville woodland which is
in my world
and this is the last significant wild
green space in my unveil
and its allocation to build development
is completely a thoughts with a climate
emergency motion adopted by the council
last summer
the argument put forward by both the
landowner and the council for including
this area in the site allocation plan
is that the whole site was originally
classified as a brownfield site
well my residents and i dispute these as
with many former mod sites the woodland
is a greenfield area
which contains a mosaic of biodiversity
and geodiversity with brooks and meadows
native edgerows and many hectares of
dense woodland
including native broadleaf species it
cannot be fragmented without permanent
damage to this existing ecosystem
most importantly as already mentioned
the site is safeguarded
from build development in the course
strategy because of the green natural
assets
such as the established woodland and
watercourse
and also because the substantial part of
it is in flood zone 2 and 3.
in the updated draft there is reference
to previous development consent
however this was on a much smaller area
and was for holiday lodges for leisure
the impact of up to 300 houses is very
different
from holiday lodges which were designed
which would be designed with the
woodland environment in mind
they wouldn't be in excess of several
hectares of woodland lost
for the original lodges and in fact i
did ask evidence
of uh why the leisure component of neon
veil
which was the original vision of the
project has been abandoned
further to the value of our trees in
locking in carbon and providing natural
flood defenses in an area prone to
flooding
and i know already of two occasions in
in the in the past month
of flooding in this area the woodland
with several footpaths as well as
meadows is very important to the social
mental and physical well-being of the
community i represent
the meonvale residents in particular
make use of the woodland on a daily
basis
and during the pandemic and the
subsequent lockdown it has been hugely
beneficial to all the residents there
and in particular to those without
outdoor space
the removal of much of this woodland
will therefore have social repercussions
to for me unveil
and according to phase five plans the
moderns will give the community
access to the most degraded part of the
wood which is adjacent
to the metal fence of the quinton rail
technology center
they have confirmed that there will be
an access road crossing the greenway
therefore interrupting the active travel
and green connectivity of the greenway
itself
this again is contrary to both of the
core strategy
and part 5 sdp
finally i want to take you back to july
last year
when the council declared a climate
emergency and adopted the motion
the cabinet the leadership of this
council
must have been aware that there will be
complex tough choices ahead
well this is one of those choices
members i ask you that the rural for
proposal is removed from the site
allocation plan as a strategic site
proposal
and the whole of the woodland site is
designated as a local green space by the
council
for current and future generations
thank you thank you uh
councillor parry
thank you leader um i just wanted to
uh express my thanks actually to john
carefort and his team
for putting together this has been a
huge amount of work that's gone through
this
um it's extremely complex it actually
took me
more than two days to go through with a
fine fine tooth comb
um i think the um proposal
for increasing the five-year housing
land supply
um element to five and a half years is
extremely
important um and we must be very robust
in this area
and i'd also like to um commend
one of my um councillor colleagues in
edward fitter in in
working so hard obviously with john
carefort on the
um i know he's been working on the
revised section of the amendments for me
and vale
and i was particularly pleased to see
that these
latest amendment sheet incorporates
the importance and the need to retain
and enhance and strengthen
the woodland walk corridors so um i do
feel the changes that have been made um
obviously have had to be made in line
with the corporate
with the um core strategy and also in
line
with the mpps planning law side of
things and i think
um this giving this extra boost and
weight
and recognizing the importance of this
area
um two local residents i'm i'm
particularly
familiar with me on vale uh wearing my
other hat as a
um and as a state agent because we've
we've obviously sold properties
in this area and i know how popular it
is um
but i think this new amendment gives me
some reassurance
that going forward um all the areas
um that the residents currently enjoy
will be able to continue enjoying so um
i'm fully in support of this proposal
and wish to thank
the officers and particularly john
carefort for all his hard work in this
area
thank you leader thank you councillor
parry councillor junard
councillor junior yes the um the
overview and scrutiny committee there
was a range
of uh voices and i'm sure pena and
ordana will
will speak more on this um from
ranging from take what would be the
impact of taking this site completely
out
to um to to other views but i'm going to
speak
not from the point of view of the ovum
scrutiny committee
but from the point of view of um the
person who chaired the
task and finished work on the climate
change
because uh it is from that particular
angle that i
i have grave concerns this
site was specified in the uh
the spd as has already been mentioned
uh on page 37 it was one of the case
studies
where the uh the the it was uh the
um woodlands and the uh the pathways
were specifically quoted as being an
exemplar
of what we would like to see in other
developments
and the you know going through going
back through the core strategy
again i note that in the course strategy
this particular area
is referred to as community woodland it
is only later
in the um in the uh the site dedication
plan
that it starts to be referred to as
plantation woodland
in effect downgrading it in its require
in its uh standard
i i really do think that um that
there is there are benefits to keeping
this woodland
as it is now and and and deleting it
from
um the aurora four from the uh the sap
as we we've seen green space has never
been more vital and covert 19 has
um has flagged that up the climate
change has become more relevant
uh since the documents were produced and
people like public health england have
also benefited highlighted the benefits
of exercise
for health and mental health i just want
to
go back to the training that we had
originally when we were given
uh an assurance by that the cabinet lead
cabinet member then that because that
the
there was reference to uh reserve sites
that these would not be needed
they've now become specific this now has
become a specific site proposal
and i'm just wondering why that when
that
that decision to move from just being a
reserve site to being a specific
uh site proposal took place does it have
anything to do with the
comments in 1.1.4 which says a key
assumption
relating to the strategy for identifying
reserve sites was not correct
and therefore since july 2019
to now in autumn 2020
a key assumption uh underlying the
identification of
reserve sites has changed fundamentally
uh
and is that why uh where we are now
changing our mind
on this and the the um
why then did we then use this as an
example
exemplar in the case study for the
climate change
spd there just seemed to have been some
some changes of mine some uh some um
people are not being clear about why
this
should be green space or why green space
should be removed
i do know that there is a designation
for local green space
but i do know that that has to be part
of a green
core strategy and i would urgently
require
that that is being would be would move
forward as part of the next course
strategy
that we do look at designation of local
green space
for community use thank you
thank you councillor junid uh councillor
o'donnell
and then councillor willie hoggins
thank you um chair
so at ovue scrutiny we had a protracted
debate around this particular site
and i echo thanks to john curford for
his work
leading up to the committee during the
committee and then in fact
offline with both council junior myself
as we came to agree upon the additional
points
and recommendations that we had as an
overview and scrutiny committee
we were driving for a sensible approach
to this to recognize
the increased intra traffic we'd all
received
with residents concerns justified
concerns
and the fact that also councillor edward
fitter had flagged up his concerns and
his
um proactive approach with regards to
trying to protect
this particular area within the district
now can i just draw your attention to
what the specific requirements were we
came up with
as the overview and scrutiny committee
um because of course this was also in
the week of 20 of 30
by 2030 announced by the government so
the protection
of this area both for mental health and
for green space was it was key within
our discussions
we said we expect the londoner works
with the district council and long
marston and clinton parish councils in
the preparation of the proposal
that all is done to retain mature trees
and non-plantation woodland
they provide additional tree planting
native species to help and achieve a net
gain in biodiversity on the site
to retain enhance and strengthen the
woodland walk corridors and ensure that
the design of the proposal incorporates
the maximum amount of possible
of the woodland areas and provide new
publicly accessible green spaces
throughout the site so those were the
specific recommendations
from the european scrutiny committee
after a long and protracted
and positive discussion and positive
co-party
working on this thank you chef
thank you council o'donnell councillor
willie hoggins
yes we've all had a huge number of
emails regarding
the preservation this woodland and you
know i'm entirely sympathetic
uh to some of the points that are that
are raised here
and it isn't just the sort of the the
housing needs in the next five years
that we're looking at
here we're actually as somebody said
earlier in this meeting it is a legacy
that we are looking here
looking at here you know we can spend a
lot of time
looking at you know um different
policies that would prevent this and
prevent that but actually
you know we've had such such a volume i
mean
there are i've received a very personal
email i'm not going to say who it was
from
um but they use this place you know as a
family place to look at wildlife
um i've written and said that we're
entirely sympathetic
this gentleman's assembling is a pedal
bike for his face two and a half year
old at the moment
in the full and reasonable expectations
to be able to use this
um woodland forever to create those
memories
we have this capability as a council to
do this by whatever means and if those
means i would have been suggested by mr
careford
then so be it but i will say this they
need to be robust because as a council
we don't want uh this sort of thing to
keep on coming back to us
we must preserve these green spaces
because otherwise we are
just um we're just uh we're just paying
lip service to what we promised
last last july and i do feel passionate
about this there are things coming to
planning all of the time
that involve you know building of houses
on green spaces
we we we have it in our gift to deal
with this
and i do really do believe that we
should thank you
thank you councillor willie hopkins
councillor cargill
thank you uh chair i think council
bloody gullah said it
straight it's a very complex situation
this
and obviously all the debate and all the
the emails that we all received
and demonstrate that i think we all
appreciate the benefits
of woodland i do i love walking in my
woods which are
close to me so i fully appreciate why
and
how people appreciate the words there
and i've been um
it's my mission to try and retain open
spaces preferably green
uh and on woodland where we possibly can
and
green belt as well so it's it's been a
passion of mine
the big problem we have got the
complexity of it of course is
the core strategy and the fact that we
have to build houses
we have to provide houses for our
residents
and uh residents will say i want a house
give me a house please because you're
obliged to do so
that's the balance we have to make on
this sort of situation housing versus
the environment and the needs of our
residents as well
so that's that part of it one of the
other things which has
come out today is a five-year housing
land supply
which i'm assuming still has the 10
buffer in it it's a 5.5 years plus 10
percent i assume
uh because obviously we can't let it get
close to the five year house around
supply
in case we do tip over currently we're
fine but that
may not last forever and especially if
we don't on building houses i was
interesting i was hearing on the
uh the mayor on the street saying that
in birmingham
they're prioritizing brownfield sites
which is
good because it means they are reusing
all of that
land that's available in coventry
birmingham places like that
which otherwise they'd just say let's go
outside into the nice green belt area or
the greenfield area
and build there so that's a positive but
it's not going to stop
all the somehow some of the houses
coming into our area and that's the
bonus we have to take against it
right just to to say houses need to be
built somewhere
where i don't want house in my back
garden either and i can fully appreciate
the views of the other residents there
what i will say is i think john
and ed i know it has been put a lot of
time and effort on this one
and i think this is a bonus for this
part which is a concert
consultation thank you chad
thank you councillor cargill so
if i can just try and draw things to
uh close the whole thing
about the revised section 713
is it's to try and provide
as much uh ammunition when we come to
negotiate with the developer as we can
i think i would pay a tribute to mr
curford
for the work he's done on this because
if one actually looks at the position in
the car strategy
and what he said in 136 and 137
it is almost certain i would have
thought that the developer will come
forward with a proposal it will be far
better to try and negotiate with the
developer
to get a solution that's acceptable to
all
because the last thing we would really
want is this to be fought out in the
planning committee
where it may well go against us so
with that can i propose to cabinet
that we look at the update sheet
and the amended recommendations
recommendations
one two three and four
and i propose we accept those
recommendations to counsel cabinet uh
can i have a second place i'll be the
second
thank you councillor cargill in that
case and will you take a roll call of
cabinet members please
yes i shall i just not as leader there
was um john kerfudge was asking if he
could come back again
certainly if you wish to come back
before we take the vote mr carefort
uh thank you leader um yes there's just
a couple of points i
thought i want to just uh clarify if i
may um
firstly that if and it's a big if this
proposal were to go ahead
uh in this entirety then some woodland
would
be retained but what we're trying to do
is strike that right
correct balance um i'd just echo the
point that this is a draft for
consultation
no decisions are being made uh now other
than
to to confirm we publish the
consultation uh that's full public
consultation for six weeks
there'll be a follow-up consultation uh
in the spring next year
uh and it's a it's at that point that
ultimately we have our final version the
plan
um so my advice advices and to consult
on this
and see what we get back in and then we
can take a
an informal view we can hear what the
landowner's intentions are
we can take in the form of you next time
round
in terms of any decisions being made
from moved
reserve site to a site specific proposal
no decision have been made uh is for
this uh
this meeting cabinet and the council to
to make that decision
as to whether uh council to go with that
proposal
um so just echo the point that it is a
draft
uh i would urge members to uh consult
and get the feedback through um can i
can i
lastly just say i'm grateful for the
thanks
members who've expressed i just need to
just make absolutely it's been a team
effort
and my team will know who they are
they've worked they've done a sterling
job getting this through
it's a particularly complex document has
been made
even more complicated by the fact we're
working remotely
uh in a covered uh situation and try to
do a collaborative project when you're
working without me it's very difficult
so can i just put on record my thanks
to the team for getting to this point
thank you
thank you mr kevin so can we move to a
vote now please
and do you want to take a roll call
yeah so um yourself counselor jefferson
uh support
councillor barker paul
councillor cargill paul
councillor harvey four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
ball
councillor parry councillor parry four
councillor shenton councillor shenton
four
councillor wardy hoggins councillor
wally hoggins abstain
thank you members of cabinet so we now
move on
to the next agenda item
which is
the proposal for a southward actual plan
that means ourselves and warwick
district
combining to produce a joint local plan
i would just say to kick this item off
before i
ask uh mr careful to take us through it
in detail
there is absolutely no doubt about it
the functional economic geography
would strongly support putting together
a joint local plan for both warwick
and stratford district one of the key
factors coming forwards
over the next few years is going to be
economic growth
and i think that a joint local plan
would help facilitate that
i think that businesses do not see the
boundaries between
warwick district and stratford district
as anything
other than arbitrary i also think that
having a joint local plan
would actually enable us to do the right
thing
not only for economic development but
also
enable us jointly to address the climate
change issues
so with that mr careful do you wish to
pick up any specific points
uh thank you leader um only just to
reiterate that
the the point that this is really about
um working more
efficiently and uh effectively in
getting
better outcomes for the residents right
across the south warranty
um i understand that the uh
the warwick district council version
this report
went through their executive last week
so that their um executives is
supportive
um what you've got uh cabinet members is
a sort of detailed report just outlining
various things we need to consider
the practical things of of how we might
start to do this
um and uh if members are if you're happy
with this
uh we can go through in in greater
detail without calling tomorrow about
how we start
to do that um if i could just draw your
attention
to uh members um it's section
where a section uh four of the appendix
which has got just got the proposed
governance arrangements
in place uh just to highlight those
to you um
i'm happy to answer any questions that
members may have um
the really the thrust of this is about
working
more efficiently and effectively and the
scope of the plan is still to be decided
um but what i would say is that this
would uh replace
our core strategy reviews he'll review
the goal strategy would be wrapped up
within the southwest plan um and we can
uh
crack on with that to plan for the uh
district and what district uh certainly
beyond 2031 possibly up to 2050.
um that's that's still to be decided
but it's really uh an initial paper just
setting out the um
the parameters things we need to think
about leader thank you
thank you mr carefort and you are quite
correct it did
actually go through uh the warwick
executive
last week so they are all signed up to
it
uh councillor parry you wish to speak
thank you leader
um i just wanted to say i'm fully in
support of this particularly as a ward
member
with my my boundary adjacent
adjacent to um boundaries and wards in
warwick district council
there is a terrific need for joined up
thinking so that
um it just means from an infrastructure
perspective
as well as housing there is is that more
cohesive and holistic approach um
to join the two the two districts
together and i think it will make a
huge difference in particular to
everybody who has
wards that are that are up to the
boundary with warwick district so i'm
totally fully in support of this and i
wish to a certain degree in the previous
call strategy we'd had the
ability to be able to have much closer
links
with our adjacent um district and
borough councils because this does make
a
huge difference and this sort of
proposal just formalizes
the process so uh very much in favor and
thanks again john
thank you councillor parry um
i've got members of cabinet councillor
cargill and councillor harvey to speak
followed by councillor junior
councillor cargill thank you shane um
yeah
again with as council parish said i
quite agree with this or totally agree
um and as as you explained businesses
don't see these arbitrary
barriers and boundaries that we reforest
they all see
we do need to work closer and closer
with what we've
committed to that and this is just
another example of it and we are
starting to get
there now with it i'm not going to say
it's an easy journey
but at the end of the day it's an
essential one
um one thing i'll just pick up for john
of course is that the government are now
trying to get these
core strategies done in a much quicker
time scale so
perhaps next year john we can get it
sorted
thank you councillor cargill councillor
harvey
thank you leader um i echo your point
um about the sensibility of taking a
joined up approach across the geography
of stratford and warwick districts
i think the answers that we will get in
terms of the course strategy
will be sounder based for it um
my particular bank of course is finance
and i know that at this stage it's not
possible
to put figures on what the cost of this
exercise might be
what i do know however is that putting
the two teams together
is likely to identify where there would
otherwise have been
duplications and overlaps and they will
be eliminated
so i'm i'm i'm convinced there will be
some
cost savings and then the other thing
which i think
is appointed to the advantage of doing
this is that we're joining together two
teams
two teams with different balances of
experience and expertise i suspect
and we'll get a stronger team out of the
two rather than
just on our own and that's not in any
sense to deprecate or cast any doubt on
the capabilities
of sdc staff i just think that a bigger
pool will will
lead to um as a specialist and skills
benefit which we can harvest thank you
very much
thank you councillor harvey councillor
jennings
thank you this is going to be very quick
and it's basically
i'm fully supporting this i mean
efficiency is
is absolute key moving forward
especially in these uncertain times
so thank you thank you council jennings
short indeed
uh councillor shenton
thank you leader um yeah again i fully
support this
we're moving closer ever closer on
it on waste and this further
in my opinion develops the teamwork
between the two districts and i think
this is a positive move and as one or
two other people have said
i think john has done a very good job on
this
thank you thank you in that case
councillor junaid
i'd just like to emphasize the uh the
point that was made in 5.3.2 which is
that this is an opportunity to to
establish a new suite of climate focused
planning policies
which we were not allowed able to do
under the last course strategy because
there had been
significant changes in government policy
at that time
so this is an opportunity to really um
to
really emphasize just how important this
is to this council
uh so i hope you will take that in mind
and i know that warwick district council
has a particular
a strong emphasis on that so that might
be something that
you could work together on but also
given the debate earlier
could i also ask for an emphasis on
the on green areas of particular
importance to local communities and
making sure that everything is done
to protect those kind of areas that are
valued by local communities
thank you thank you councillor junit
your points are noted and very well made
so can i propose members of cabinet that
we
accept the recommendations uh one to
five
on page 25 do i have a second to please
i seem to have ian shenton first
uh so ann do you wish to take
a roll call of uh members of cabinet
please
yes i will so um yourself councillor
jefferson
four thank you councillor parker
four councillor cargill
paul councillor harvey
four councillor jennings
councillor jennings four
councillor parry four
councillor shenton councillor shenton
four
[Applause]
thank you members of cabinet in that
case we move
on to item six on the agenda
and the people portfolio councillor
barker
stratford on irvine district council
housing strategy
2015 to 21 action
plan um i i'm not going
to do the disservice of going through
the whole darn thing
but i am going to just point out a few
bits and pieces and i don't know whether
renata
is here but if she is and wants to say
anything in addition then
that would be very welcome the
recommendations are the report is noted
and also secondly that the revised
milestones in the strategy
15 to 21 action plan are adopted
um and the milestones and the reasons
for this
are uh if i take you to
oh sorry i've been talking too much
today by the sound of my voice
um if i take you to page 46 1.5
talking about work on the preparation of
a new housing strategy
um and the reason that it's been delayed
so
we're just extending what we've got at
the moment um difficulty in engaging
extensive changes
to planning and the necessity of
concentrating on policy and development
the sorry the team on securing
affordable housing
if i then take you to page 47
2.6 the milestones 24 of them have been
achieved
you can go on through there and four are
unknown um i would say that
uh the unknowns tend to fall into the
homelessness
category and that because of the kovid
response
um and the everyone in and the still
trying to keep everyone in
scheme which i i still called everyone
in
um that that we have succeeded in and
had quite a lot of work on
that was aim three of the vision in the
strategy
the homelessness one which we've been
really aiming for
um then if you go through you've got the
commentary on the milestones and
what's worked what hasn't and we're
pretty much on target
um
and then you're we're referred in item
three onwards to
uh whether we can adopt them as percent
the strategy is presented
or considered or any change is
considered appropriately
i would suggest that we will be adopting
it as it is
um and that going forward with the new
council plan and the new strategy for
this um
towards 2030 uh we have we are aiming
for high quality appropriate and
affordable housing across the district
and delivery of that will be will
greatly assist us in that aim
and i utterly supportive of that
finally just refer you to item seven in
the conclusion that a new housing
strategy is being prepared
action plan then follows all these
lovely colorful diagrams
which have things that you might have
questions on i don't know
and my recommendation
is as at the beginning
that we note the report and that we
adopt the revised milestones
thank you thank you
i have counsellor parry and councillor
harvey
uh wishing to speak councillor parry
thank you leader and first of all can i
um
give my thanks to the portfolio holder
and the housing team for putting this
very comprehensive
report together i just wonder whether i
could just
um highlight one particular
element which revolves which concerns
the epcs
i just would like cabinet to note
in my professional capacity i can advise
that if a property
is not being remarketed for sale or
rent it doesn't need to have
an epc at the rate of
um e and in addition to that
a high proportion of landlords will have
epcs which are f and g
um included on the epc exemption
register
it perhaps might be helpful if the
housing team
checked the epc exemption register
before sending letters to landlords
advising them that um
the enforcement team will be taking
action um
because i have had first-hand experience
of having such letters so um
and any landlord can get their property
put on the epc exemption register
if the energy insulation costs
exceed three and a half thousand
including that
and they have to provide three quotes i
just wonder whether the team might just
like to take note of that
thank you leader i've taken note of
that counselor barry and we'll pass it
on thank you very much for your
wise notified thank you councillor parry
exceptionally technical input there
councillor harvey
uh thank you leader i wonder if i could
ask members
of the cabinet to turn to
page 62.
there's a reference at the top of that
page
to empty properties and
was a target of uh bringing 30
properties back into use
in 2019-20
um i have made the point at a number of
meetings
about my keenness to see section 106
money which has been
accumulated in relation to affordable
housing
being used as quickly and as
productively as possible
my concern is that the amount of money
we've got is not very much when you
consider
uh the cost of a an affordable house is
typically put at something of the order
of 160k
four million pounds would lead us to be
able to to build
uh something of the order of 20 houses i
suspect 20 houses
is a drop in the bucket in relation to
housing need
in the district i'm mentioning that
because i'm trying to link together
empty properties and section 106 money
and i wonder if there is some scope
for officers to be creative
in linking together
how we can improve um
and amend and adjust uh and
alter um these houses
the uh um the empty houses
uh and bring the using 106 money if
necessary
in order to bring them into use it
strikes me that
spending 20 or 30 000 pounds on a house
to improve bathrooms kitchens wiring etc
etc
if that's the problem we we have a
capacity to
spend more money and generate more
affordable housing
much more quickly than if we tried to to
work towards a solution
which involved us building so this is a
plea
to put 106 together 106 money together
with empty houses find as many as we can
and spend as much money as we need to
in order to get as many affordable
houses back onto
back into use as quickly as possible i
can see that uh councillor barker
is about to shut me up no
no i'm about to agree with you
councillor harvey
shall we shall we raise this together at
hip
i see that uh mr weeks would like to
speak so he may
be about to tell us we can't do it but
hey absolutely
would you like to respond to uh
councillor harvey's suggestion
chairman general thank you um yeah a
very
very welcome suggestion and as the
portfolio
has suggested i'm sure that dialogue can
be continued perhaps
at the housing investment panel but just
to give council harvey some comfort
the council has had for many years a
capital pot of funds that we have
offered to landlords
in order to or property owners not
necessarily just landlords in order to
encourage them to return their
properties to
reasonable use in return for us then
being able to use those properties for
an amount of time
after being returned into use sadly the
the scheme that we've introduced and
have updated over several
years doesn't seem to have really gelled
with landlords and they've not
rushed to accept our offer so um i i
wouldn't want to leave council harvey
with the expectation that the additional
of section 106 monies would would
necessarily
crack this nut we have we have tried
over many years to do this but
the landlords have a host of very very
different reasons for holding properties
open
uh empty um and and i think that's
that's one of the challenges that we
face but nonetheless we can certainly
examine it
chairman thank you thank you mr weeks i
now have
uh sorry councillor barker do you wish
to interject at this point
yes i i just wanted to interject on that
point that yes we do
it is complicated the number of um
number of times that under my revenues
and benefits hat
i am asked to um discount or
zero uh council tax on various
properties
is it's not huge but there are some and
you know when you've only got
like four walls no roof um or they still
haven't sold a place because
you know it's in it but they're trying
to and they haven't got probate and that
kind of thing
there are many reasons why um it doesn't
always work but but
i think in principle we need to push on
ahead with it but we have struggled as
uh mr weeks says thank you councillor
barker councillor junaid and then
councillor kettle
uh yes just a couple of queries if i
might um one
is on page 59 you've got reference
in point 13 about the feasibility of
setting up a council
owned local housing company is this
still ongoing um and
what what progress it yes progress there
secondly uh i actually think you know
section 106 and
empty properties is is something that
should be looked at
uh on page 59 as well we also we're
talking about the
gypsy and traveler and travelling show
people spd
uh presumably that's on track uh and
is the county council uh helping and and
supporting the
district council with um with
ensuring that we meet our obligations
for
um gypsy and traveler sites and finally
a lot of the housing and affordable
housing in particular
does rely on a good working relationship
between
housing associations and the biggest one
of those in our area is orbit
now you will know and i'm sure officers
will know
that there has been considerable and i
mean considerable difficulty
uh with with orbit in recent times uh
over
repairs and um you know shortage of
suitable housing particularly where
there are children involved
how do we develop and work better with
orbit how can we
make sure that um you know not only do
we understand their problems but they
understand ours
um thank you councillor junior and
answered your first question it was yes
um not a lot of progress um
because as you may be aware there have
been a few other things that we've had
to sort out recently
um your final point about orbit
and bronford and any of the others we
work with i have
meetings with um
[Music]
various of the housing associations i
also meet with um
warwickshire rural i'm at the cpre all
sorts of people who have input
into what we want in terms of housing
and in terms of what we provide
if people come to me
um and i don't mind my inbox being
filled up with their queries
i will put them to orbit and i do
i do scour the stratford-on-avon
um forum site i
and colleagues uh send me stuff from
there and the same with all the other
local
facebook sites where people are having a
go about orbit and things that are not
happening
so we push them through as best as we
can um
we're not living in particularly easy
times
and i think i actually think that when i
speak to the senior
um executives at orbit we get a very
very good hearing
one of the problems is that it doesn't
necessarily percolate down and that's
what we're
trying really hard to work on
thank you councillor barker councillor
kettle
thank you um yeah just um i was actually
a pick up on
council junior's point about um you
mentioned gypsy
travelers um over the weekend we had
um an invasion of i think and i think 16
um travelers or travelling vehicles in
another
unauthorized site clearly the delivery
of
um clean and well-managed official sites
is something we really have to push
forward with because i know
it actually costs this council a
significant amount of money
uh clearing up after unauthorized
traveller sites are dedicated
and i think um in my ward we had the
prize for having
one of the dirtiest uh
ex science left behind which um
angela lloyd had to clean up on our
behalf but i was also just going back on
point
17 about bringing empty properties back
to use again
on orbit um some years ago i managed to
persuade
one of the senior executives in orbit
not to sell
uh two properties in one in my ward
um because they weren't in very good
condition those properties have now been
empty for some two years
and it is a huge pity
that orbit rather than actually taking
the opportunity to bring those
properties back in for use by local
residents
uh they're just saying they're empty
nothing nobody has even
mowed the grass or even done anything to
them we really need to press on
orbit with i know they've got limited
resources but what is the point
in having properties which are empty uh
if we persuaded not to sell them
so it's portfolio
i would i would truly rather not hear
the word invasion used i think that's
really pejorative so please
try i know that it is difficult
um my rugby club suffered a similar
uh campaign incident and it was
difficult
um we are doing again it's another thing
where we are doing our best
quite honestly i can't see anyone
sitting around this
virtual table who would happily have
a gypsy and travellers site the bottom
of their garden
and that nimby problem
is what it's about question
that that's uh sorry and the empty and
the empty houses just give me the list
of
of it and i'll i'll bash him over the
head with it again because
the chief exec who i saw quite recently
said what a good job you're done in
trying to save whatever houses or
bungalows they were so
there seems to be again there's a
mismatch thank you
thank you
i would just say on the invasion it is
uh a difficult word to use
but when they cut through uh county
council barriers that have been put up
specifically to exclude them
and then i had a report this morning
that
members of that group were using
people's gardens
for uh i'm not going to describe them um
you know what i mean that is invading
people's
premises for completely inappropriate
use
i think we get the message counsellor
kettle councillor whaley hoggins
uh yes i was just going to say with
regard to the egyptian traveler site
there can be some sympathy really
towards the gypsies and travellers
we have been trying to get a site and
sorted out suitable sites sorted
for them and as you've just spoken about
christopher kettle that you know county
council they've cut through barriers
that the county council have erected to
prevent them from going into certain
spaces
um most frustratingly the county council
has also
put up metaphorical barriers because
they flatly refuse to engage with us as
to where
we might put or have a gypsy and
traveler site that is suitable
and there is there are a lot of benefits
and gains by
by allocating and having a controlled
gypsum traveler site
not least of which is the fact that we
can have a
cctv camera positioned right on site so
that we can make sure that any uh
any uh undesirable behavior if there
were some
can be dealt with so actually i actually
have some sympathy here that
everybody deserves a place in which to
call their home and which
wherever to put their home so we have to
continue
to put pressure on the powers that be to
allocate
a suitable site uh for this um
for for this for the significant group
in society and
i like uh jay barker i do not want to
hear
them being pilloried we need to support
and pressure and
and find somewhere suitable uh for these
for these uh
transient residents to live i'd also
like to say this about some of the empty
properties that we have within our
villages
what happens is a lot of these empty
properties when they become empty
because usually it's older members
of communities die they've got as we
said
heard earlier from uh councillor banks
you know they've got old-fashioned
central heating systems they use
solid fuel central heating uh that that
kind of thing
and you know is it is it viable for for
new residents to take on the
um the the expense of running
uh houses that are that expensive to run
you know that that is that is the
reality
and it is a pity that we're not in a
position to pass uh
such properties onto parish councils so
that they
can manage uh the the renting of these
properties
so that um local people local younger
people perhaps can take advantage of
them
and move in so that they can be of
greater use of their communities
thank you thank you i also want to
challenge
fine in that case can we move on to the
recommendations on page 45
uh the recommendation is that the report
be noted do we need
take a vote on this
um you could perhaps ask if anybody has
anything
that they want to raise against agreeing
yes they can put it in the chat
have anything against the
recommendations on page 45.
i'll take that as a resounding no in
which case we move on to
uh councillor willie hoggins item seven
class q technical guidance councilor
willie hoggins
well the queue is in the the clues in
the title here technical guidance and
because of that very phrase i'm actually
going to hand over this to the eminently
suitably qualified
and experienced richard gardner because
he will be able to shed
a great deal more light on this matter
than i
actually can it's a very full report for
you today
full of such technical matters richard
over to you
mr gardner i'll struggle i think
chairman i think i'll struggle there
but i will go i'll give it a go um
yes it is technical um and it is um
outlined in in the report in front of
you um
you'll see uh section 1.3
um the key thing that drives the thrust
of the report
is the existence of a guidance already
both in the um the general permitted
development order
class q itself which is quite a
technical document
and also the planning practice guidance
which is the national guidance that the
government publishes and updates
regularly on its website
so those two pieces of guidance exist
already
and they significantly inform officers
and other parties when they're
submitting and considering class q
applications
at section two of the report um you'll
see
um the the for and against
in effect on having guidance on these
class q applications um and really the
the key um matter for
having this is just to provide a little
bit more of a local slant
on um having um interpreting
and bringing together all of the
existing guidance and perhaps some case
law
on class queues against it
um the general summary would be that it
would repeat
existing guidance and therefore there's
no need for it
and that it would run the risk of
becoming out of date
uh very quickly as indeed the heritage
here one has
because the government regularly updates
the mppg
um it would need to be kept on top of
and all the time it would be duplicating
it anyway
um the other point now i'd just like to
highlight
is that our appeals performance on class
queues is very good
it's close to three quarters success
rate which is uh marginally higher than
the general success rate for
uh planning appeals both of which are
above 70 percent
and the recommendation is that
the guidance isn't produced specifically
for stratford and we continue to rely on
the gpdo
and the the planning practice guidance
that the government produces
happy to take any questions thank you uh
before we do that
can we uh just say and i believe we have
a
a member of the public wishing to speak
on this and do we want to bring them in
now yes i would suggest that we bring
them in first to speak
um so as stewart if you can hear me
could you please unmute now
yeah i am here thank you very much can
everybody hear me
yes well thanks very much for the
opportunity to speak um i'm stuart
keithley i live in ludington
um i'm in speaking in support of the
motion to adopt some guidance for
for brought by councillor pertiguella
there are a lot of bonds to house
indications coming through
there were over 50 last year and there's
been 35 this year
only half of which have been approved
the financial incentives for developers
are very significant and
planning agents are now actively seeking
to promote these conversions i think we
can expect many more
and class q can be contentious as uh
councillor pertiguella pointed out
barns are not just quaint cotswold
buildings they can be huge
tin sheds often in village settings
where
they can have significant impact on
neighbours and the village character
a key issue is the structural condition
and suitability for conversion
many dilapidated bombs are possible
houses but
they need a lot of work and might not
comply with class q
um i live in luddington we've had two
recent applications in reviewing lots of
applications as a result i've seen a
lack of consistency
in approach by different case officers
and established that
case officers have made errors in
process for both the applications in
laddington
one of those i got through freedom of
information request and the other
through a complaint brought directly to
the planning team
and similarly i've seen very variable
quality
in the evidence that's provided by
developers since this is permitted
development
the legislation is open to
interpretation it's not clear-cut
and it's well documented that there is
inconsistency in approach by
the different local authorities and this
is why some have sought to improve
matters by
issuing guidance and and some guidance
is out there with other authorities that
is kept up to date
i have to disagree with the planning
officer dismissing the proposal for
guidance
because there are consultations involved
and there are matters of judgment in the
determination
process so i think if if we brought
guidance in it could improve the details
submitted
by the applicants improving consistency
it could provide clearer demonstration
of the structural suitability for
conversion
and the extent of works required it can
ensure that evidence is
provided by developers rather than
unsupported statements
it could ensure site inspections
validate the developers claims
30 seconds rather than the present desk
study approach
and it could also clarify the legal
status of class q after approval when
bombs are sold on and are no longer part
of farms
so in summary there's already guidance
out there and some of it's up to date
adopting guidance could improve
consistency significantly
and it could reduce errors in the time
the cost of determination
for the planners and those involved in
consultation
and that's my uh my first three minutes
up i think
thank you uh i have wishing to speak
outside
mr gardner do you wish to respond to any
of that
um just to pick up on one point i i've
got some sympathy with
some of the difficulties that all
parties face with class q guidance but
it's very stringent
in terms of how it's set up the gpdo and
the information requirements and
the hoops that you have to jump through
and some of the things that were
mentioned there are already in part x
of the gpdo um so again i'll repeat what
i said we would just simply be
duplicating what is already there
if we were to have guidance okay thank
you mr gardner
i've got councillor shenton councillor
parry and councillor willie hoggins
thank you leader um i i when this
was was brought up um i was originally
uh originally spoke in favor of more
guidance on this
but um because of the the
if you like the the the point about
barnes being converted but in particular
dutch barns that were basically
um dilapidated and were being tried
to be forced through for housing but the
key part
of of of uh what richard has put
together here
for me is on page 67 and
the council and where it says the
council's own document
would have no way for decision making
purposes
and so could not be considered a prudent
use of resources and then further down a
couple of
paragraphs later we talk about our
success at class q
it would seem pointless to
waste resources developing something
that will not
move the planning on any further so i'm
content
personally with the recommendation now
thank you councillor parry thank you
leader
um i'm fully in support of the response
from the planning officer i mean i do
fully appreciate that councillor peter
geller is a very new councillor on board
and also councillor rock um as a member
of the planning committee
for nearly um five six
i think it might even might be seven
years now um
certainly a couple of years ago we had
an excellent um
training session on class q and i i just
wonder whether it might be
very helpful for those two particular
to have this training training session
and it might just um bring them more up
to date about how we approach
class q and it's probably a very good
one to be honest with you for all
counsellors
in view of our rural awards so
my view is is greater education so that
they fully understand
the process and the um
mppg guidance thank you leader
thank you councillor parry an excellent
suggestion as soon as we
really begin to get training back on
track i hope that will be taken up
councillor willie hoggins
uh thank you leader the point i'd like
to make is this that
that farming um is changing
the small rural farms uh are
becoming a thing of the past really so
we are going to be
um because they're not financially
viable so
for example in my constituency we had an
old dairy farm that was the the
applicant wanted to convert that to um
dwelling um and it tooed and froze for
months and months it was
it was it was not a our finest moment
really
and one of the planning people involved
in that said but if we
grant this it will never be able to
become a dairy farm again
well that wasn't the point really the
point was it was never going to be a
dairy farm again because it wasn't big
enough in order to be a sustainable
dairy farm so we do have to be mindful
of the changing times here
and surely sometimes it is better to
have development than to see buildings
in our rural areas
going to to to raccoon rock and ruin
for me sometimes it's good to have
challenges as we had from uh
councillor portaguella and councillor
rock because actually it gives our
it gives us a chance at our cabinet
meetings with exactly these things
brought to us by uh
richard gardner here to show everybody
and the world and
that uh actually we are very robust we
do know what we're doing
and uh you know this this this class q
document in itself
is excellent and uh so yeah we have to
be mindful of changing towns especially
with rural buildings
and they always have to look at what
kind of a rural building is it is it
made of concrete with a tin roof
is is that is that viable really and do
you really want that there
could you build something better thank
you
thank you councillor willie hoggins
councillor cargill
thank you leader uh my concern over this
proposal
is that it could could literally
backfire on us um
we've already said that it duplicates
guidance
it would need significant officer time
to
not only draft it but also maintain it
and as we know developers will exploit
any
weakness in any system at all so
i'm sorry i'm quite happy with this i
think it would be
wrong to actually start messing about
with us when we have
good guidance and the robust evidence
base that we are doing the job properly
so i'm happy with it thank you in other
words councillor cargill
are you proposing that we accept the
recommendation on page 65
i would like to propose that we
recommend it accept the recommendation
on page 65.
do i have a second to please members of
cabinet
councillor shenton thank you uh in that
case
could you take a roll call please um
yep yourself councillor jefferson
support
councillor barker support
councillor cargill paul
councillor harvey four
councillor jennings paul
councillor parry councillor parry for
councillor shenson councillor shenton
for
councillor warley hoggins councillor
wally hoggins four
thank you thank you members of cabinet
in that case we move on to
item eight on the agenda which causes me
a bit of a problem
on the grounds that it is listed in the
agenda as community portfolio
but on the paper for item eight it is
listed as
councillor harvey
i'm quite happy to take this if you um
would like
leader uh i think given it's more likely
to be financed than anything else
please do so councillor harvey
thank you um this is a very
uncontentious uh proposal
this is simply a matter of asking
cabinet to regularize
the position in relation to uh
the southern leisure center so that
the district council takes a lease for
66 for 60 years
at a peppercorn ground rent and that
will enable
the district council to negotiate
a management contract for this
particular site
thank you councillor harvey i see no
counselors
wishing to uh speak
um so in that case the recommendation
on page 69 you are proposing acceptance
of that counselor harvey
i am indeed can i have a second half
counselor
ian shenton is seconded can we do a roll
call please on
yeah yourself leader
support councillor barker
for councillor cargill
or councillor harvey
for councillor jennings
councillor jennings ball
council of harry councillor parry for
councillor shenton councillor shenton
four
and councillor wally hoggins councillor
wally hoggins four
thank you members of cabinet uh in that
case moving on to
item nine community fiber broadband
program councilor cargill thank you
leader
um well long time coming uh it's
very encouraging that the department of
uh culture media and sport actually
contacted us about
this particular element we've been
working
closely with them they all went very
quiet elections etc
uh and coded 19 and then they came back
and contacted
uh david platts and we have now had some
meetings
and the consequence of that is
that we have been given their strongest
guidance yet that they are going to
actually do something
okay now what we now have got to do
is to keep them honest now what by that
what i'm saying
is that once we get this rolled out
we need members all of our members to
start engaging with their
local communities especially the rural
ones who are out on the on a limb
without
decent broadband speeds at the moment
and to go for the voucher scheme
there should be no cost to the the
residents
and we the stratfor district council
will support them
uh as much as we physically can i'm
happy to come out with them knocking on
doors putting leakages out
just to try and encourage everybody to
to get out there and apply for the
scheme
uh obviously we'll see what happens
about that one but at least then
we will get um open reach
and keep them honest and get them to
putting fiber into our remote
communities it's really an encouraging
situation
thank you thank you councillor cargill i
have councillor our councillor clark
you have a question councillor parry has
a question
and then council o'donnell wishes to
speak
question from councillor barker thank
you
um i want to just ask whether
i'm very glad that we appear to be
making some progress
um on this and that you're right we need
to keep them honest
um and to keep them on on task
can you answer whether individual
um properties are going to be part of
this as well
um for instance farms down a track
i would ask dave david platz if he would
like to respond on that one but
uh i do know an answer but i'll let
david respond on that and he wouldn't
mind
mr platz thank you leader uh yeah just
to come back to councillor barca um
it would have to be part of a group
whether that be
a number of farms who brigade together i
think is the official
term that they use for those properties
that are in the in the more rural areas
so in terms of just one person coming
forward
um it would it wouldn't be acceptable
under this scheme it would have to be a
group of
um closely geographical businesses
who came together um to form a legal
entity with
bt and and that group whether that be a
community group or a parish council or
whatever
thank you mr platts counselor para you
have a question
and then uh councillor o'donnell
councillor parry
thank you leader i just wondered whether
do we happen to have
any form of mapping initiative that
actually
highlights those villages
and properties that have a specific need
because i think
that would be really helpful to see
um down on a sort of a granular award
level
yes we do and yeah we can work on that
one no problem at all
if i could just come in there lately
just to answer that answer that as well
i i think that
um councillor cargill is absolutely
right i think for the first time
this this gives us the a real
opportunity to see
the actual level of the current
connection
who's left and what a reasonable cost
and time frame would be to answer that
so i think it would help
on all fronts councillor parry so yeah i
think
for the first time we're going to see
something where we can actually grasp
that nettle
can i just ask that if we've got that
data
um when we do an analysis of what the
picture actually looks like
is that worth reporting back to cabinet
absolutely absolutely thank you council
o'donnell
thank you leader um so we're pleased to
ask ons to see that there is progress
being made
and obviously you'll recall that there
has been a lot of involvement with ons
and trying to scrutinize broadband and
therefore we would ask
that updates are brought back to ons
so that we can assist with scrutinizing
what is going on and support you with
this progress that's being made
thank you council o'donnell and talking
of scrutiny i believe
councillor kettle now has a question
yeah this is just in response to um mr
platz's
comment uh good afternoon mr platz um
the the idea that um it will only be
available when
um farms are in close proximity to each
other
actually in a way redefines farming
because farming premises are by their
very nature remote
um and we heard earlier on about remote
farm buildings under the section
q debate about conversion
um none of that can happen no
conversions can happen nothing can go
into businesses unless you've got a
broadband connection
um and it the areas which have missed
out consistently
and as you know this is something i've
been tracking quite some time leader
have been those separate rural
um very small hamlets or
farm buildings because actually all the
settlements have been picked off uh
they've been dealt with either by
uh open reach or whoever else may be
doing it it
is those individual properties and i
think at the last camp when i had
numbers
it was something like three and a half
thousand properties
where the coverage was appalling
now that's not our fault and i'm not
pointing the finger to anybody in the
district council for that
but it does mean that if you require
farms that maybe half a mile three
quarts a mile apart
are excluded then the rural aspect
will never deliver and it is that aspect
that we see in other areas in other
countries which are being dealt with
which this country has simply failed to
deal with
thanks councillor kettle i think we're
getting a picture
uh councillor do you want to pick up
followed by mr platz
i'll do it first and then daddy can pick
up first things first
if a farm is a business then all of a
sudden they are
able to claim the three and a half
thousand pounds which can go into the
pot
and again what they've been telling us
is that
if for example they are laying fiber
between two villages and you have to go
past a farm as an example
then there is no reason why they can't
look at doing that sometimes they'll ask
for the farmer to
help them dig the trench and such like
to make it easier but not forgetting
that there is wireless technology is
well available
so we can actually still pick up these
remote areas without having to lay
cables down there
and get good speeds as well david did
you want to pick up anything on that
i i just wanted to say that in direct
relation to
councillor kettle's question this was
the this community fiber broadband
program is the one that individual
businesses
don't qualify under but there are other
broadband schemes still
going around as council cargill says but
in terms of the community fiber
i guess the names in the clue they're
looking for the communities to come
forward
having said that i'm sure that if
anybody saw the sunday times article
a week last sunday there were a couple
of farms in the lake district who'd been
quoted 500 000 pounds by bt
to get the fiber to the property so i
think that we can expect some
significant costings in some of our
areas
but again just coming back to the point
i made earlier i think for the first
time we'll actually see
how much those connections are likely to
cost whereas before it's all been
part of the contract one contract two
contract three with bd uk
and for the first time we look like
we're going to get to the granular level
that councilor parry mentioned thank you
mr platts
i think it will be fair to say that it
does appear that at long last we are
going to make progress on this
and i think what i would also like to
say
is that the relationship building that's
actually being done with dcms
between dcms and the district i think
he's now beginning to pay off
so i think both councillor cargill and
mr platts
uh deserve thanks for the efforts they
put in there
so the recommendation on page 73
uh councillor cargill i would assume you
are proposing it
i would like to propose that on the
recommendation on page number three
please just
earlier do i have a second uh
thank you i have a lot of secondary but
uh councillor parry was first uh and do
you wish to take a roll call
yourself leader uh four
councillor barker
councillor cargill paul councillor
harvey
four councillor jennings
ball councillor parry
councillor parry for councillor shenton
councillor shenton four
thank you and councillor wally hoggins
councillor wally hoggins for
thank you members of cabinet that was
carried unanimously
uh we now appear to return to the people
portfolio
and this is the kelvic 19 community
recovery action plan
which i assume is not going to be known
white's acronym
i'm gonna try so hard not to call it by
its acronym i really am
i did i did pick up that acronym when
this was first noted and suggested that
calling it that was not
such a good idea but we will leave it as
the crap
and i think it's wonderful that the crap
comes before the dog fouling order which
is the final item
on the list today
now now i've done my stupid bit let's do
the really serious stuff this is
this is really really good news this is
something we've done fantastically well
kovid came and hit us and some of us
worked ridiculous days
trying to um work out what on earth the
government meant to do
and um some of us still are and
the social inclusion partnership of
which i am
part which you will see at 2.1 convene
to discuss how we could support one
another
the the different voluntary groups and
non-voluntary groups and expert partners
like cab
uh and how we could work together during
that and that has gone on further
into the community recovery action plan
which is based on the
all the data analysis and a whole load
of
statistics that we have gathered in um
and if you then
turn to page 83 you'll see 80 yes sorry
83 you'll see the key actions
and the priority themes that we've come
up with and those are things that we
as i said in the social isolation
partnership we talk about
anyway but here
here are the key actions that we've
taken across all the themes
so from page 83 onwards until you get to
the nice colorful picture
at page 96 i think it is
um which shows you um
the social impact of what has happened
with kovid
during this period so for instance
compare
just april 2019 with april 2020
in terms of the food bank 707 taking up
food bank parcels in 19 1322
in 2020 and um
[Music]
anecdotally uh i was one of the people
who counted the parcels in a food bank
and we were very very thorough about it
and we knew how
how much food we'd got and so very so
just that small example will tell you
we did an incredibly detailed load of
work
so without any further ado
uh unless uh mr cat is here and wants to
say anything
um i would like us to agree
the crap
and note the dashboard and the digest
that goes with it
thank you for watching thank you before
we put this to a vote counselor
counselor counselor junior do you wish
to speak
yes um can i thank you for for the
report
and it's a it's a good piece of work but
um
can i um can i say that that this the
worst is probably yet to come um
page 95 uh it shows in color
some of the um the worst of the
statistics and page
102 shows that there is 185
186.5 6.5 increase
in claimant count levels um
we are not probably the worst we are not
the worst
in in the west midlands but the
percentage
rise in our area is particularly stark
and i'm just thinking that the work is
not yet done
because the next year will probably
bring hard further hardship as more
people
start to lose their jobs uh so
i i do i do wonder
whether um we stop here with this one
report
or whether we actually take it on in
some way
to make sure that people are not left
uh in in very difficult circumstances
uh i also have to say that because i um
it's mentioned in this
report i am an act on energy trustee so
i probably ought to mention that at this
point
um because that's also with winter
coming
we are going to get more and more people
in very very difficult circumstances
trying to keep
not only food coming into the house not
only trying to
keep money coming into the house but
also trying to keep things
warm and comfortable as well thank you
councillor parker do you wish to respond
yeah just just briefly thank you very
much councillor junaid i i take on board
what you're saying and
our percentage change is high it
reflects
the kind of work that is done by so many
people
across this district um
you will be happy to know and knowing
the portfolio
holder slightly as you do that if it's a
recovery action plan we are going to be
taking action and we do carry on meeting
as a social inclusion partnership
this is the beginning and if you notice
that the data is driving the priorities
and the priorities
have tasks that are underway tasks that
are uncommenced etc
and so this is an ongoing project
thank you councillor barker i now have
councillor willie hoggins
councillor harvey and then councillor
o'donnell
councillor willie hoggins yes i was just
going to say i mean i'm i'm not sure
is this is this actually just for noting
venus
how i keep calling it covered one and
kobe 2 really because actually we're now
since the start since the this report
was
written we're now in a very different
situation i would i would suggest
to it's no good shaking your head joe
barker you know the we are facing
unprecedented times
once again with ever rising numbers here
so does this paint a particular picture
that is perhaps not going to ring
through for very much longer
and that we note this as an interim
report and then move forward you know
next year with with the other you know
the recovery action plan
that is all i'm saying that that's that
the
the key is in the title here you know
we've got a lot more work to do probably
with a lot more people probably in about
four weeks time
i would suggest when the redundancies uh
start start mounting up
with the end of the furlough scheme
thank you counselor
we have got a lot more to do if you i
mean i i didn't run through this in
detail because i'm not going to bore you
for britain but
if you look at the dates this is a
2019-2024
social inclusion statement project it's
a group that does it
it is ongoing we know that the end of
october is going to be a nightmare we
know the statistics are going to get
worse we know lots of people are going
to be in poverty in stratford
which is not something that we have come
to expect
so i i commend the officers
and the social inclusion partnership who
work really really hard to put this
together and of course
is a moving feast i i don't
think there's any element of that we've
got we have got
health and well-being groups in ulster
in shipston in various places looking at
all the social isolation
elements of this and working as we have
done before so
i don't think you can regard this as
kovid1 and kovid ii i think this is just
an action plan that goes on
counselor willie hoggins
i think what i was trying to say is that
this is this is a point for just
for acknowledging the hard work that's
gone on so far but also we need to
acknowledge the fact that there's a
great deal more
uh potentially hard work to follow that
that is that is that is the issue here
that we can't and that's what i've said
fine
right moving on councillor harvey and
then councillors
junior and o'donnell councillor harvey
thank you very much
um uh canada junied um
drew attention to page 102
and the rise of 186.5
um i don't wish to minimize that but i
do want to draw attention to the fact
that it does depend how you present the
figures
if you take the figures for march 2020
and place them in rank order stratford
would have been 18th despite the
deterioration
to june 2020 stratford's relative
position
would only have gone to 17th so
what these figures show to me is um
there's plenty of suffering
going on elsewhere in in the district
and in the
in the region um but the main point is
that
we started from a very low base
proportionately
and absolutely and that's why the the
the increase
in proportionate terms is the size it is
from 1000 to three thousand
but my point is is simply there are
plenty of other places
uh that have got it really really bad
although birmingham comes out at the
bottom on one scale of
only an increase of 59 that's nearly
another 30 000 people
who are making claims that's my point
thank you councillor harvey councillor
o'donnell
thank you leader it was simply to advise
that
when nick had presented this at ovue
scrutiny and we'd like to thank him for
his exceptional work on this we were of
the opinion it was an ongoing project
um and we were very supportive the
action plans
and we thanked him for his hard work and
our simply for updates and to be kept
updated and i do think that having
listened to the discussion council of
wolly hoggins actually does raise a fair
point that we are nowhere near
through this yet and it's it's
reassuring to hear councillor barker
that it is an ongoing
action plan so thank you for that
thank you council o'donnell so
councillor barker has proposed that we
accept the recommendation on page 79
they will have a secondary please
have a second thank you councillor
cargill
so and i think once again on this given
that we have to
agree uh the community recovery action
plan we need to take a vote
so yourself later for
councillor barker or
councillor cargill paul councillor
harvey
four councillor jennings
henson jennings sport councillor parry
councillor parry four councillor shenton
councillor shenton for the council of
wally hopkins
abstain council holly hopping hoggins
and stain
[Music]
thank you members of cabinet moving on
then regulatory portfolio
councillor parry public spaces
protection order for dog fouling
thank you lead i can see you've left um
one of the best topics
to to the last
um first of all in bringing this report
to cabinet
um i would like to extend our thanks to
karen dixon
for her work in not only preparing this
report but for her time
with stratford district council in
environmental health
um dog fouling is probably one of the
issues
that residents are most concerned about
as it's not only deeply unpleasant
but can also be very dangerous
particularly to young children
whilst rare contact with
dog feces can cause toxocareosis
managed to get that one out and us it's
a very nasty infection
um that can lead to dizziness nausea
asthma and even blindness so it's it's
really really serious so this report
is therefore really important it's
extremely important
as it proposes the extension of the
current
public spaces protection dog fouling
order
for a further three years so
in terms of background um this council
actually approved the fouling of land by
dogs
back in 2009 which then was converted
automatically to a public spaces protect
order
in december in october 2017
and it's remained at within that
um for the last three years but it
lapses in a couple of weeks time on the
20th of october
um whilst we recognize the majority of
dog owners
and i like to call myself within this as
well we're responsible
we clear up after our pets unfortunately
there is still a small
minority of people who allow their dogs
to foul
um without clearing up um
so and in fact we we're in a situation
that whilst the
the number of reports of dog fouling has
actually decreased
um we still receive nearly 100 reports
on dog filing each year but i can assure
you
it's far higher than that because you
only have to go to your parish council
and it's on the agenda almost every
month
so um the level of
impact amongst residents is actually
much higher than currently evidenced
through the consultation
so one of the key things is obviously
educating dog owners
um the council the team do an awful lot
of work in terms of
providing signage leafleting going
around hot spot areas
and they've been continuing this focus
so
i hope cabernet is going to support the
recommendation
to agree the extension of this order and
also
to agree an increase in the fixed
penalty
fine from 75 pounds to 100 pounds
the key is always trying to catch
somebody in the act
um so vigilance is certainly important
but i think
we do need to highlight as this is an
ongoing issue
so thank you for your support and any
questions
thank you councillor cargill you wish to
speak on this
thank you very briefly uh lydia first of
all i'm a little bit shocked that ulster
wasn't on the list
of on console teas because to be honest
with you i get
lots of complaints about jog poo and i
have spent
many a happy hour going around with a
stencil and spray
uh with a pick it up and ben it and sort
of like signs
uh of course i support this cancer parry
uh without a chat of a doubt yeah thank
you very much indeed
councillor dixon
thank you leader uh it's a question uh
essentially
um when i'm out rambling i too often
i find little black bags which have been
hung up in trees
um now the question is is that
going to be covered by this act because
obviously
the dog owner or person with charge of
the dog
has cleared up the mess but have
disposed of it inappropriately
counselor parry do you wish to respond
well the key
the key to all of this is having
evidence
at the end of the day um and for parish
councils
certainly um to have bin's
dog bins strategically placed now
obviously the
there is a cost implication to parish
councils but i
urge all ward members
to make sure that there are sufficient
dog
bins in the right location i
i agree that you do find walking about
bags on trees
um and i think sometimes dog owners
perhaps put them in the event that
they're going to
collect them and then they find they go
a different route or totally forget
but the key in prosecution is
in catching people on camera
and to in my view um
fouling isn't properly disposed of
unless it's put in
it's either taken home and put in a bin
or put in an appropriate dog bin
and not in the general litter bin please
thank you councillor parry councillor
shenton
yeah just a general comment and that the
the problem i
i agree totally with councillor parry
here that
the problem of detection um this exists
with
with fly tipping just moving i'm just
looking at the comment in there does it
rattle
no the the problem with uh with
with this is detection there is no
evidence
and that that's a big problem the the
scale of it though
is that there's i'm just looking on the
keyboard keep britain tidy site which
um i i'd look at being that kind of
person
um it's a thousand tons of
mess every year it's a massive problem
but you can't put
cameras in every location you can only
appeal
to people's better nature and education
is the key i guess you know
so more dog bins please yes thank you
councillor shenton
uh councillor parry i assume you are
proposing the recommendations on page
115
absolutely sir can i have a second to
please
thank you councillor jennings uh
and do you wish to do the royal call
please
yourself leader uh for
you councillor parker four councillor
cargill
councillor harvey if i'm eligible to
vote i
vote for councillor jennings
councillor jennings four councillor
parry
councillor parry four councillor shenton
uh as as for cancer harvey i declared an
interest but i'm
four okay and i think um councillor
wally hoggins has had to leave the
meeting indeed that's the message in the
meeting
yes just before the vote was taken so
thank you members of cabinet so carrying
on through the agenda
part c issues arising from osc
non although they were covered in the
fourth item on the agenda
kevin of committees none on block items
the only one
is the member development working group
and these are for noting
uh urgent business actually there is one
item of urgent business
um it's the road closures for hs2 and mr
buckland do you have an update on
the road closures for hs2
no nature and i have no update at the
moment other than what was discussed on
friday
where we've been notified that the a425
will be closing for a period of nine
months
uh starting at the end of october so we
we have
um trying to contact hs2 for
a discussion around that i understand
the uh the diversion route is somewhat
of about 14 miles
so we will be taking that issue forward
but yeah i know update further
sign thank you so as soon as we get any
update we'll circulate it to all
uh members of where all
the council is actually just about to
finish it's all right come on in shut
the door
i know you can't stay but it's good to
see you guys
right uh
normally items of urgent business
need to be uh counselor cattle you wish
to speak is it a matter of urgent
business
it's relating to the closure of the a425
um i attended um a meeting organized by
local
councils um on thursday
uh that's when we first had notification
the meeting was on friday afternoon
um since the last item on this item i've
actually spoken to local business who
i've been waiting to come back to me
uh one of the largest agricultural
dealers in the
uh district um there was no consultation
the closure of a main road which is an
access route for hgvs
to junction 12 was bad enough last year
but now by moving an additional
roadblock in
for nine months you're blocking access
from
southam to lemington southern to warwick
uh other than as
mr buckland has already pointed out a 14
mile diversion
there were no there was no consultation
with any party
beforehand and quite clearly from the
way the
presentation went uh there was no
intention to vary
or take on board any of the comments
that were made
there were no answers no suggestion
that we will consider
and i think this is a major issue for
the eastern part of the district
when in a nine-month closure of a main
road
is going to have a significant economic
impact
on businesses and residents understand
council of cattle and when we actually
get to speak to hs2
we will take it up with it in the
strongest possible terms
so thank you councillor kettler so with
that
i'm closing the meeting thank you
everyone
it's been over two hours but there's
been an
awful lot of big items discussed so
thank you for your time thank you for
your effort
and uh have a good evening thank you
you